hey this is preshtal Walker here's a
delightful question from the
international mathematical Olympiad in
1976.
determine the largest number that is the
product of positive integers whose sum
is 1976.
interestingly three years later on the
Putnam competition there was basically
the same question for 1979.
I guess in the pre-internet days it was
easier to reuse the same sort of
question without all students already
knowing how to solve the question
we can also generalize the problem let N
be a natural number greater than zero
choose natural numbers X1 to XK such
that their sum is equal to n and their
product is equal to p
the question is to determine a formula
for p
I thank yarik for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so let's start working out a few
examples we have a number n and we want
to figure out its maximal product of its
partition
so let's say n is equal to one we can
only have one partition which is one so
the product will be equal to one
what about n is equal to 2 we can either
have two or we can have one plus one
it's clear that two will be the larger
product so p is equal to two
we advance to three so now we either
have three two plus one or one plus one
plus one
obviously the largest product is three
so p is three
when we go to four we can have four we
can have three plus one two plus two
two plus one plus one or one plus one
plus one plus one
again it's obvious that 4 is the largest
product but we could also have two plus
two because two times two is equal to
four so p is equal to four
now what if we go to n is equal to five
there are going to be seven partitions
of five
so just examining these different cases
we can see the largest product is going
to be three times two which is equal to
six so p is equal to six
now let's go to n is equal to 6. there
are 11 partitions of six so it's going
to start getting difficult to write out
all of these partitions but we'll just
do it in this case
now what is the largest product we can
work them out pretty easily and we can
see it will be three times three and
that will be equal to 9.
so now we've worked out a few cases and
we can conjecture what the solution
might be
so if n is greater than 6 we can imagine
that the best strategy is to choose as
many threes as possible and then we
might need a couple of twos
so how can we prove this
so let's get started so first of all we
never want to pick a number that's equal
to one
it'll just be wasted in the product
if we have two natural numbers X and one
that'll be a smaller product than just
the number X plus one this is clear one
times x is less than X plus one
so we never want to choose one
we also never want to choose a number
that's greater than four why is that
well you could take that number that's
greater than four and you could split it
into two numbers so we have the number
minus two and two
so that number will actually be a
smaller product than x minus 2 and 2. so
here's how we can see that so we have 2
multiplied by x minus 2 that's equal to
2x minus 4. now if x is greater than 4
this is larger than 2x minus X but 2x
minus X is equal to X so we've shown
that the product of 2 and x minus 2 is
greater than x when X is greater than 4.
so you never want to choose a number
that's greater than 4.
so All That Remains is between twos and
threes now notice that if we have two
plus two plus two that's equal to 3 plus
3 which is equal to 6. but 2 times 2
times 2 is equal to 8 and 3 times 3 is
equal to 9 and that is larger than 8.
so we never want to have three or more
twos it would be better to have two
threes instead
so most we're going to have two plus two
or just two
now it will be equivalent to choose four
or two plus two because four is equal to
2 times 2. so we might as well just pick
twos to keep things simple
so that's our strategy we want to pick
as many threes as possible and we might
need a 2 or a two plus two depending on
the number
so which option we pick depends on the
remainder of the number by three
if n is equivalent to zero mod 3 then n
is evenly divisible by 3 n is equal to 3
times K so then we can pick all the
threes we want and P is equal to 3 to
the power of K
another case is if n is equivalent to 1
mod 3 this means n is equal to three K
plus one in this case we're going to
need two plus two so p is equal to 2
squared multiplied by three to the power
of K minus 1. the final case is n is
equivalent to 2 mod 3 then n is equal to
three K plus two so we just need one two
so we have p is equal to two multiplied
by three to the power of K and we've
solved the general case
so now let's solve the international
mathematical Olympiad problem
so we need to figure out this problem
for 1976. now 1976 is equal to 658
multiplied by three plus two so we have
a remainder of two
so P will be equal to 2 multiplied by 3
to the power of 658.
to solve the Putnam problem this is
three more so 1979 is equal to 659
multiplied by three plus two so p is
equal to two multiply by 3 to the power
of 659.
so that solves the problems
but this leaves one question what is so
special about the number three that we
want to pick as many threes as possible
so first let's consider the amgm
inequality
so if we have non-negative numbers X and
Y we have the square root of x
multiplied by Y is less than or equal to
X Plus y all over 2. so the geometric
mean of X and Y is less than or equal to
the arithmetic mean of X and Y
now if we Square both sides of the
equation we get the product of x times Y
is less than or equal to the square of
the arithmetic mean
now remember we have equality if and
only if x is equal to Y so in other
words the maximum product of X and Y is
when X and Y are equal to each other so
we want to get the numbers as evenly
equal to each other as possible
so if we have X1 X2 the sum of all this
up to xn equal to S then we want to pick
the maximum product will happen when we
get the numbers as close to each other
as possible
so let's suppose we have n numbers of X
and that's equal to this fixed sum s so
we'll consider a continuous case we can
have fractional numbers
so we want to maximize the product which
will be x to the power of n now from the
first equation we can solve that n is
equal to S divided by X
so this means the product is equal to x
to the power of s over X
so this is a function of X now which we
can maximize we'll maximize the function
x to the power of s over X
so how can we do that
well the trick is we write Y is equal to
this and then we take the natural log of
both sides so we can bring down the
exponent
from here we can use implicit
differentiation
so on the left hand side if we take the
derivative with respect to X we have y
Prime divided by y then on the right
hand side we use the chain rule so we
have the first term multiplied by the
derivative of the natural log of x which
is 1 over X plus we have the second term
natural log of x multiplied by the
derivative of s over X and that's equal
to negative s over x squared
we can then simplify this so we have a
common denominator so we have y Prime
divided by Y is equal to S multiplied by
1 minus natural log of x this is all
over x squared
from here we multiply both sides of the
equation by y
but now we remember that Y is equal to x
to the power of s over X
so now let's analyze the derivative
we know that s and X are greater than
zero
so x to the power of s over X will be
greater than zero and of course one over
x squared is greater than zero so the
only thing that might affect the sine of
the derivative is the term 1 minus the
natural log of x
so we analyze this this will be positive
when X is less than e it will be zero
when X is equal to e and it will be
negative when X is greater than e
so we have a maximum when X is equal to
e which is approximately equal to 2.718
so now think about the original problem
we have a sum of numbers and numbers
that's a fixed sum s
we said we want to pick as many threes
as possible and we may need 2 or 2 plus
2 depending on the number so what's so
special about the number three well if
you look at the continuous case we want
to get as close to e as possible when
we're limited to whole numbers we pick
the number that is closest to e and that
will be the number three and that is
what's so special about three
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time